[Music]
this is the story
of how i met your father
it was hard to live in the moment in
2022 there was always someplace else you
could be someone else you could be with
i know this might sound crazy but i've
been on 87 tinder dates this year my
last date was the worst one yet i was on
another day before this and i just had
sex he told you that why would he tell
you that that's not even the worst part
do a night of new friends this is the
best place ever repeat after me today is
the first chapter of my next great love
story today is the first chapter of my
next great love story
it must be sophie it's a real pleasure
oh my god
screw being mature yes we can still make
bad choices for a few more years
this is the best night of my life when
you tell the story in the future just
promise me you will change that part
we live in confusing times valentina you
are completely insane i'm very into it
it's really hard to meet someone and
connect and have it feel easy you gotta
get back out there sometimes yeah ever
since meredith dumped you i've been
spending 50 bucks a week on kleenex
because you're crying or because you're
going to town on yourself crying bro
both
together we will take this city by storm
we are not afraid of you new york we're
the bravest people in this city
i'll drink to that
[Music]
you